so there is a border battle underway in
my home state of Texas so far Governor
Abbott is showing no signs of cave to
the Biden administration's demands
instead of giving control of their
border back to the federal agent Texas
is installing even more razor wire to
crack down on the migrant illegal
Invasion watch Texas has a right as a
state to stop criminals from coming into
our state to make arrest of those
criminals and we have National Guard as
well as Texas Department of Public
Safety officers who are there to make
those arrests and to deny illegal entry
and Joe Biden actually does have an
option here Joe Biden's option is to
enforce the laws of the United States
and stop this illegal entry it just it
is just Greg Abbott now 25 Republican
Governors are siding with Governor Greg
Abbott signing a joint statement and
support of Texas South Dakota's Christy
gnome is one of them and she's heading
to the Border today today Oklahoma
governor Kevin stit is also back in Abit
and he'll join us later in the show
former justice department official in
the Trump Administration Jean Hamilton
saying quote unless and until a federal
judge comes in and says you may not
state of Texas put razor wire up along
the border anymore Texas should keep
doing exactly what it needs to do and
eventually this turns into a game of
will between the feds and the state of
Texas now unsurprisingly California
government Gavin Newsome is coming to
Biden's
defense I thought that was shameful what
was reported out that he's just
completely rolling over and capitulating
don't even get me started with the
weakness of the current Speaker of the
House I mean they don't want to deal
period full stop they don't want to deal
they don't want to make this quote
unquote campaign win for Joe Biden says
everything you need to know about the
fraud that they're perpetuating on the
issue of the Border they want to make
this a political issue
consistently and of course when it comes
to resource ources border funding is
still tied up as Republicans and
Democrats struggle to find a compromise
on spending we're going to continue to
covering this throughout the morning
we'll let you know where we uh where we
get over to you guys yeah so it's
amazing we're watching we're watching
the country divide again right before
our eyes and I it's hard to defend going
against Texas you're in the wrong you're
on the wrong team if you think that
Texas the federal government is doing a
good job at the border 25 States back uh
the back the Texas governor they all
Republican states I mean can you believe
we are watching The Divide of America On
the Border issue but on other issues too
I mean if Donald Trump was President
right now they'd be saying this guy is
terrible for the country we've never
seen anything he doesn't know what he's
doing but it's the experienced guy
that's doing this well and Donald Trump
is uh telling Republican Governor send
more National Guards from their state
down there more uh with Kevin stit as uh
Lawrence just said a moment ago Lawrence
was live at Shelby Park that Park where
the governor that was Grand zero I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis